let's bring in our panel up top here
match slap contributor with the hill Amy
Walter a national editor for the cook
Political Report and Tom Bevan
RealClearPolitics co-founder and
publisher Amy first - you hope Hicks you
know it's hard to overstate her
importance for this president candidate
Trump and then President Trump she has
been there I mean it's part
communications director but part body
man or body woman with the president
she's literally been there by his side
from the very beginning and person that
he trusted probably more than anybody
who wasn't in his immediate family so
this is somebody in the inner inner
innermost circle at the same time I do
think that John's point that he made at
the end there about the issue of saying
that there are times that I have said
white lies I've never said anything that
was outwardly false or was an a lie
about the Russia investigation but your
job as a White House communications
director that's a pretty damaging piece
of information to get out there that
anything that is put out on the record
by your White House communications
director has to come through that filter
of somebody who is admitted to saying
things that aren't true at different
times so I do think that's a piece of
this I also don't have to be clear that
White House communications director and
press secretaries in the past have said
things that are absolutely not accurate
not true but they haven't been quoted
before New York Times hasn't had a
headline that says X acknowledges she
sometimes tells white lies three at the
same time I also don't doubt that she's
ready to go nobody can live at this
level I think most folks can make it a
year or two at this pace and they are
ready to go usually you see somebody
leaving at the mid term it's really hard
to believe they could make it much
longer we should point out chief of
staff John Kelly put out a statement as
well when I became chief of staff I
quickly realized what so many people
have learned about hope she is strategic
poised and wise beyond her years she
became a trusted advisor and counselor
and did a tremendous job overseeing the
communications for the president's
agenda including the passage of historic
tax reform she has served her country
with great distinction to say that she
will be missed
is an understatement Matt your thoughts
on this and what it means for this White
House I think it's a big deal I think
it's it's a big piece of news I think
presidents put people around them who
they're comfortable with who who they
trust who they have a relationship with
and when someone who has this type of
relationship leaves it's it's it's hard
for a president now I think what's a
little different about this president as
I actually think it's not going to
change that much when people who are
very close to him go from inside the
circle to outside the White House he
still obviously communicates with him
regularly and I think I don't think her
relationship will change that much but
the physical proximity every morning
starting off planning the day responding
you know it's hard it's hard for
presidents when this happens and White
House communications job a big one to
fill there's another person named
schlopp who's in that team Mercedes we
should point that out as you're here on
the panel who may have a bigger role now
but it is a big job especially for a
White House under attack it is a big job
in some ways you know Trump is the
communications director of his
administration via his Twitter account
but two things really one is that I
think regardless of what the White House
says the timing of this is bound to
encourage speculation of the you know
grist for the pundit and rumor mill
about what really drove her to make the
announcement she's not leaving anytime
soon she's not like she's being run out
of the building but to Matt's point
Trump has lost another person there very
few in fact there's only one dansk Avena
the social media director who who is
part of his original team he lost Keith
Schiller his body man he lost he's lost
a lot of folks that he really does trust
to be in that building with him and you
know we'll see how that plays out but
but there are very few left outside of
his family now inside the building with
whom he has those sorts of bonds I want
to play
just moments ago Senator Richard Burr
was asked about hope Hicks resigning he
obviously is the chair of the Senate
Intelligence Committee
they didn't provide for us
any information
investigation that we have and basically
Amy both Democrats and Republicans said
this she took privilege on a lot of the
questions that had to do with her time
in the White House she answered
questions about the transition but nine
hours every question every angle every
kind of combination up on Capitol Hill
yesterday right and there was but you
know again this is where we are at this
point in in politics in Washington
Democrats are gonna be frustrated
Republicans are gonna say she did the
best of her ability there was no
possibility as Senator Burr said we
didn't see any opportunity to say that
this is about collusion I don't know if
that's it that was certainly a big issue
yesterday but again I think the bigger
question as we move into the midterm
elections and think about what's gonna
happen afterwards is who's going to be
around the president in the second half
of his first term again there's normally
a lot of turnover at that time but
presidents prepare for that they know
who the next team is going to be that to
take the place now we I don't think we
have a lot of answers on which you know
sort of who's in that pipeline to come
up not just for this job but I think
we're gonna see a lot of turnover in
much bigger jobs but who is the Trump
whisperer
inside the White House now I mean hope
Hicks clearly was I don't know if that
changes I mean they have I've seen it
they have a very tight relationship
she's probably the number one staffer in
many ways for the longest period of time
worked for Ivanka before that I don't
see that relationship changing I think
he's going to reach out to her and talk
to her on a regular basis I also think
Donald when you get down Trump his
number-one relationship is with his
family and he's going to continue to
talk to them as well then he has all
these people he's known for a very long
period of time throughout his business
career he is constantly reaching out to
people in polling them and asked them
and getting feedback it's why it makes
them an effective communicator because
he is actually talking to people on a
regular basis it does come last thing
here
as there's this security clearance
question Jared Kushner the son-in-law
fathers the Donald Trump's son-in-law a
senior advisor we talked about it
yesterday but there are many others a
few dozen were told who had security
questions and maybe even a downgrade
as far as clearance so that's also
happening at the same time and there's a
lot of things happening at this White
House yeah look I think John Kelly's
trying to deal with the the issue of
security clearances sort of writ large
inside the White House but the Jared
Kushner security clearance issue is one
that has garnered the most attention
because of the portfolio that he has the
proximity whether he can do his job
without having the top-secret security
clearance and I think that remains an
open question but a lot of this
speculation about I think his security
clearance we saw this Washington Post
article the other day which I just
thought was was unnecessarily you know
ominous about him being manipulated by I
mean this he's the son-in-law of the
president United States and certainly
the president can grant him need-to-know
authority for anything that he needs to
do so I think that's been a bit of a red
herring a bit too much made about that
okay panel thank you